one of our our favorite guests
throughout the year and he's entering
his 13th season
in the national football league uh the
head the quarterback of the atlanta
falcons and one-time mvp of this great
league of ours matt ryan back here on
the show how are you matt
i'm doing great rich thanks for having
me on man always appreciate you coming
on
um this is just a weird world that we're
living in right now what has it been
like for you
getting ready for this season no
preseason games protocols left right up
and down
young kids at home matt what has this
been like for you
you know what it's it's it's been
different uh for sure
i mean i think everybody would say that
the last six months
uh have been a whirlwind and definitely
you know have taken some adjusting to i
think camp
you know going in without preseason
games for sure is the biggest change i
mean it's been
uh you know this is year 13 for me so
it's been you know 13
plus years since i've gone into a season
without you know knocking some of the
rest off with uh with these preseason
games so that part is
difficult um you know i got to give i
got to give the nfl credit i got to give
our organization credit though they've
done a
they've done a really good job of
you know taking care of the players
making sure everybody's safe
uh and trying to do the best they can
given the circumstances so
i'm excited we've made it to this point
we're about a week and a half out and
uh you know everything is looking like
it goes so i'm excited about that me too
matt you know i mean obviously
nobody has the answers nobody uh you can
only
figure out what's best and try and and
get through it um but here you are
you're with the uh you and the falcons
are getting set for your
your opener uh in just a couple of
sundays from now against
seattle and it this looks like it's
going to happen what do you what do you
think i'll ask you the question i'm
asking
uh veterans and young players alike when
they've been kind enough to call into
the show
the the chances do you like the chances
of getting through 17 weeks with no
delays and obviously nobody has the
answer but based on everything that
that you know and the conversations that
you've had with your
teammates and your teammates have had
with you or you might have had with
other players around the league about
um being safe when you're not at work do
you think you're going to get through 17
weeks uninterrupted
this season you know i i i certainly
hope so
i think i think it's been a positive
that
you know we're i i guess i've been
testing every day since july 23rd
and uh you know our numbers have have
stayed low
and so uh i think that part of it is
you know definitely you know one one
that would you know lead you to be
optimistic i think
as we begin to travel and and there's
you know different games obviously
there's
uh external factors that that are there
that currently aren't there but
i am optimistic you know i i guess you
know by nature i'm that way but i i
think guys have um you know are making
the sacrifice to to be as safe as
possible
when you're outside the building and uh
being as responsible as they can be
so um from what i've seen so far
you know i i really have no reason to
not be optimistic unless
you know things change and and we don't
know if that's going to be the case but
uh right now as i sit here i feel really
good about it matt ryan here on the rich
eisen show how has todd gurley looked
up close and personal to you it's been
impressive
uh you know he's i
i got to spend some time with him in the
offseason we put a little work in on the
field and i was just
blown away by how professional he is how
smart he is you know his
his ability to recall information you
know really quickly
uh but the most impressed i've been was
we had a scrimmage at
at mercedes-benz stadium uh last week
and
it was first time kind of the lights
went on uh
and it it was you know kind of a little
bit more of an atmosphere he's got a
gear
uh that he can kick into uh that was
impressive to see
and not all guys have that you know some
guys have the ability to
to just take it to another level when uh
you know the lights come on and it's
time to go live
and he certainly did that uh last week
which impressed me
and um you know i'm excited about it i
think he's going to be a really
really good fit for for what we do
offensively and
a nice piece to uh to to us scoring
points
no obviously uh we we all know what what
todd gurley can do
and two years ago for me to follow up by
asking well what can he do in your
office
like how does he fit in your offense it
would have been a silly question two
years ago right
but i i can't get an answer i couldn't
get an answer from anyone from the rams
uh or anybody about why we sometimes saw
him on a stationary bike
or why the 25 touch guy
showed up every other three weeks um
he looks healthy to you he looks like
todd gurley
to you matt yeah he does you know i
can't speak for
for you know any other stuff that you
know was going on before here i can
speak for
you know the last probably three months
that that i've been able to
to kind of get to see him on the field
and and he
has looked like he has uh progressed and
continued to get better the entire way
uh and he's looked great during training
camp he really has um
so he looks he looks healthy to me uh
he's looked you know really good uh
running the football for us catching the
football for us and
in practice and um you know i'm excited
about
about what he can bring because like you
said i mean his production
uh you know throughout his career has
been
you know incredible and so um
if we can keep him healthy and and keep
him feeling good
i don't see any reason he can't be as
explosive as as he's ever been
matt ryan here on the rich eisen show is
this the toughest of
nfc south you've seen in your baker's
dozen years now
in it well yeah it didn't get any easier
this often
well i mean what better i just try to
find an eventful way of saying hey tom
brady's in your division huh like i
can't just
that's basically what i tried matt i
just tried it
yeah it's it's it's it's gonna be tough
there's no question about
it i'm going into year 13 and i'm like
i'm one of the young guys in the
division right
[Music]
now it's like cocoon you're right you're
right yeah
these are two guys i was watching you
know in high school and college so
that's right uh it's it's it's it's kind
of funny that
it's taken out that way but it's gonna
be tough there's no question about it
uh but you know i feel good i feel good
about our team i think
you know we're probably flying under the
radar a little bit and uh that's okay
i feel like you know we played some good
football in the second half of the
season we had
uh you know some good wins on the road
which is great experience for some of
the young guys in our organization
i'm hoping that you know translates into
a fast start and a successful season for
us
did you just play that nobody believes
in this card a little bit very quietly
did you just play that card in that
conversation i wasn't saying nobody
believes in us i'm gonna say we you know
we probably haven't
been getting as much attention as some
of the other teams in the division
that's all
well i i i guess okay i guess i might
have twisted a a little bit right there
but
they're your words not mine that's true
okay uh what
you mentioned brees brady obviously uh
and the way you guys
started last year that might be why
people are not looking at you more
but the way you guys finished last year
i mean that was
pretty damn impressive how does that
work
from one season to another because that
was significant with your coach's job
flat out on the line and the teams that
you beat at the end including the
ultimate nfc champion and damn near
almost
uh super bowl champion i mean how does
that work from one year to the next
matt yeah um you know i i think
it look i mean last year was it was as
strange a season as i've been a part of
uh to have the first half of the season
go the way it did and then the second
half of the season
uh to play as well as we did you know i
i i just
i've never really been a part of
something like that and uh so so that
part was unique
i think i think we were playing some
young guys like
on our offensive line we had guys like
caleb mcgary and chris lindstrom you
know
playing a bunch for us in the second
half of the season chris got hurt in the
first game
uh and then didn't play until the last
four games of the year
and i think you know i think for young
guys you know it's important to
to learn how to win in this league to
learn how to go on the road to learn
what it takes
how disciplined you have to be uh how
how well you have to execute i i think
those are the things that carry over
the experience of of of what it takes in
order to be successful
i'm not sure necessarily the momentum
right that that
that doesn't carry over but the lessons
learned do and
and that's what you know i'm hoping uh
you know i mentioned those two guys but
we have we have young players across the
board at wide receiver for us calvin
ridley
uh russell gage who played a big part of
our second half of the season
all those guys were you know it was a
learning experience for them and
and it should be a confidence booster
that the you know their routine and
their schedule and their mindset was
right the second half of the season
uh and to continue to do that uh as we
move forward
and in terms of just the way that you
finish up this year i don't know if this
was coveted related to make sure that if
there was anything that needed to be
pushed back at least the end of the
season would be played
you do face uh the saints
and the bucks both times you face them
all after you're by week 11 and 13 is
the saints and then week 15 and 17
is tampa with the chiefs in between i
guess you're going to have to
bring last year's finish to this year
too with the chargers and raiders
in the mix matt yeah no question it's
loaded so seriously uh and the first
stop is too so
it's it's uh you know the good part of
division games late
uh is is it gives you a chance to you
know to do what you need to do in
division
uh at that time of the year and and
hopefully
you know the good teams i've been on
have been the ones that get better as
the year goes
and start peaking at the right time late
in the year uh and hopefully that's the
case for us because we're going to need
it we're playing good football teams
at that part of the schedule let's have
a little fun with matt ryan before we
send him on into his atlanta day chris
ask him the poll question
right here on the rich eisen show it's
kenner reeve's birthday so chris
brockton came out
what's the best keana reeves movie okay
here's what we got
point break speed john wick or the
matrix
uh i think the matrix uh what is what
what what is the poll revolt saying
yeah breaks pretty good too okay okay so
we're almost at 6000 votes the matrix
the matrix is at 33.7 john wicks at 33.5
all right i'm in the majority man that's
good i got to admit to you i've never
seen point break
oh old school that's worth an after i
mean
with covet this last six months what are
you doing
i've been i've been doing this show but
i guess you know
what like like what have you seen in the
uh in your quarantine what have you been
doing
what have you seen oh my gosh i mean
we've we've kind of crushed
netflix it was tough i'm a big sports
fan okay and so
uh you know and my wife is as well and
so our typical
you know tv watching is is sports and so
uh when everything shut down it was like
oh man what do we do
and so we we definitely we crushed a lot
of netflix okay
um you know which was good uh we're
i'm watching this series dead to me
right now okay uh
which i'm not sure if you guys have seen
but it's twisted it is that
kind of dark and funny so so that's
pretty good right now but
we've kind of just been hammering out
all kinds of netflix so what's your
favorite sports movie man
oh man i've kind of gone down a rabbit
hole a couple times watching
some of your youtube stuff when you have
the actors on and you're going through
uh
you know some of their like uh all of
the talk about a few good men
i've been down that rabbit hole with you
talking about the other actors okay
quite a bit excellent favorite sports
movie
oh man uh i've got a suggestion for you
matt
have you ever seen this it's gonna be
the natural right
that way robert redford
he's so great in it he's
good we had that on vhs when i was a kid
growing up i used to watch it all the
time
so you relate i can't i can't relate to
it
that was a thing that one up perfect
rich you gotta move on
you gotta move on that was the last time
mike i know but
and you cut out he told him telling me
that i love you but you gotta move on
you cut that part out do you remember
that chris i don't remember that part
i don't remember that
[Laughter]
i was so sneaking in the back door and
you saw it coming that's why you
got your head on a swivel professionally
so that's why you are who you are man
well maybe maybe year 13 is the year it
gets going
matt i look i really tried matt i tried
to get him to lay off and do it straight
yep i have done it straight i told him
it's a great sports movie what's wrong
with the
the the natural he is relentless i gotta
give it to him
matt thanks for the call as always
always appreciate our time together
you're the best guys take care right
back at you that's matt ryan
smart enough to go down to rich eyes and
show youtube wormholes
as well